il ya dépenses celles aussi d'où l'on
rentre bredouille
et puis d'autres franchement surprenante
de l'eau sorte les objets les plus
aimables pour avoir un bric à brac oms
mines chambre 40e blanc et bien cette
pêche insolites des employés de la ville
de paris vient de la réaliser en
procédant comme tous les sept ans la
toilette du canal saint martin richer il
aime tant le fera elle devrait pas
traîner
l'atmosphère d'hôtel d'une aubaine pour
un joueur d'une infirmité l'ombre de
jouvet ou d'arletty dans les eaux du
canal saint martin il est due par tous
les temps ont effectué un grand
nettoyage qui permet de récupérer
quelques sommier de nombreuses
ustensiles menalt de réfugiés en heure
la nuit longue liste retrait pour coup
d'une centaine de deux roues plus ou
moins garni de coquillages dans ces
objets sans âme qui n'ont pas su se
faire aimer
on note un nouveau rival 14h59 bel
avenir
vingt secondes avant livrer le lit du
canal aux ouvriers chargés de réparer ce
déplu au bulldozer qui vont évacuer des
centaines de mètres cubes de balman
trois générations et c'est moins d'une
minute la pêche grosso viognier ball
aussi curieux que cela paraisse le 3e
ligne orange contrebandière sauver près
de trois tonnes de poissons
essentiellement du gardon en utilisant
une méthode miracle la pêche électrique
c'est le rêve des pêcheurs on met deux
des quatre îles sera exactement ce qui
pour sauter dans le vide
23e minute unifiée quelques centaines de
mètres plus haut
là où il reste de l'eau est rendu à
leurs éléments peut-être referont il
encore le voyage dans sept ans